mr
president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhof americans and
the world when day comes we ask
ourselves where can we find
light in this never-ending shade
the loss we carry a sea we must wade
we've
braved the belly of the beast we've
learned that quiet
isn't always peace and the norms and
notions of what
just is isn't always
just this and yet
the dawn is hours before we knew it
somehow we do it somehow we've weathered
and witnessed a nation that
isn't broken but simply unfinished we
the successors of a country and a time
where a skinny black girl descended from
slaves
and raised by a single mother can dream
of becoming president only to find
herself
reciting for one and yes we are
far from polished far from pristine but
that doesn't mean we are
striving to form a union that is perfect
we are striving to forge or union
with purpose to compose a country
committed
to all cultures colors characters
and conditions of man and so we lift our
gazes not to what stands
between us but what stands before us
we close the divide because we know to
put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we
lay down our arms so we can reach out
our arms to one
another we seek harm to none and harmony
for all let the globe if nothing else
say this is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
that we'll forever be
tied together victorious not because we
will never again
know defeat but because we will never
again sow division
scripture tells us to envision that
everyone shall sit
under their own vine and fig tree and no
one shall make them
afraid if we're to live up to our own
time
then victory won't lie in the blade but
in all the bridges
we've made that is the promise to glade
the
hill we climb if only we dare it because
being american is more than a pride
we inherit it's the past we step into
and how we repair it we've seen a forest
that would
shatter our nation rather than share it
would destroy our country if it meant
delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated in this truth
in this faith we trust for while we have
our eyes on the future
history has its eyes on us
this is the era of just redemption we
feared it at
its inception we did not feel prepared
to be the heirs of such a terrifying
hour but within it we found the power to
author
a new chapter to offer hope and laughter
to ourselves so
while once we asked how could we
possibly prevail over catastrophe
now we assert how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us we will not
march back to
what was but move to what shall be a
country that is bruised but whole
benevolent but bold fierce and free
we will not be turned around or
interrupted by
intimidation because we know our
inaction
and inertia will be the inheritance of
the next
generation our blenders become their
burdens but one
thing is certain if we merge
mercy with mites into mites with rights
then love becomes our legacy
and change our children's birthright
so let us leave behind a country better
than one
we were left with every breath from our
bronze pounded chest we
will raise this wounded world into a
wondrous one we will
rise from the gold-limbed hills of the
west we will rise from the wind swept
northeast where our forefathers first
realized revolution we will
rise from the lake rim cities of the
midwestern states we will rise from the
sun baked south we will
rebuild reconcile and recover and every
known nook
of our nation in every corner called our
country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge
battered and beautiful when day comes we
step
out of the shade aflame and unafraid the
new dawn blooms
as we free it for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only we're brave enough to be it